You should come out of this pandemic a changed person.
Yeah, not every day is going to be great,
but every day is what you make it, period.
So I went from hating people to loving people
is my favorite hobby on the planet.
Man, I live to give hope.
And it's so much easier, Evan, to be happy.
Happiness is a choice.
We can go through hell and come out on fire.
We don't have to be bitter.
We don't have to be angry.
We don't have to stay stuck on stupid.
We don't have to stalk them on Facebook.
We can get up, pick ourselves up,
and realize the harder I fall, the higher I bounce.
And there she is.
Hello, how are you?
Real Talk Kim in the house.
Yes, in the house with you, Evan.
I'm super pumped.
The people don't know Real Talk Kim.
She's a pastor.
She's a dealer of hope, which I love.
She's an author.
She's a speaker.
I love that you, one, dealer of hope.
And I love the loudness that you bring.
And I mean that in the most positive way possible.
It's loud, and a lot of people have a hard time
stepping into their voice.
So can you first talk about, all caps, hope dealer,
what does that mean to you?
You know, I think that life is so hard,
that you need some people in your life that
just aren't trouble, people that don't
suck the life out of you.
And that's what I am, man.
I think that for so long, I depended on people.
I depended on relationships.
I depended on my dream board getting accomplished,
expectations that I had for my life at a certain age
to happen.
And when they didn't, I found myself in depression.
Following through with this, man, the society
told me I should be here.
And here I am just flopping at life.
And man, when I was about 36, 37 years old, man,
I had an epiphany.
I walked through something in my life
that I never saw myself walking through.
And I found out in those three to four to five years
that I am a hope dealer.
And like, nobody is going to pick me and you up, Evan.
Nobody's going to say, get up.
Come on.
Let me just bottle feed you.
Yeah, it's OK.
Nobody's going to do that.
And if we don't learn how to focus on the big picture,
focus on I might be down today, but I'm
getting my butt back up.
I ain't staying here.
I might have a meltdown, but I'm not staying here.
And so I think that's what it is.
That's where I found out that, man, I live to give hope.
And it's so much easier, Evan, to be happy.
Happiness is a choice.
Even when things aren't going right,
even when we're in a pandemic and you're getting furloughed
and you're losing your job and you're fearful,
you know what I'm saying?
Nothing is going to change that.
We're here, except the way you think of things.
And you realize that as long as I got a pulse,
God's got a plan.
And so that's where Hope Dealer came in.
I just bounced, man.
I bounced back up.
I fall and I get back up again.
And talk to us about developing your voice,
because you found your voice.
It's, you're unabashedly you.
And we've had other pastors on
and they don't have the same energy or buoyancy
or just loudness, right?
And it's refreshing and it's different and it's awesome.
And I don't know if this was always you
or you kind of came through this journey.
So tell us about how you found your voice
and you're so willing and courageous
to step into it every day.
Well, you know what, I was raised in a religion
that basically said women couldn't preach.
Women were only good for having babies, cooking supper.
And here I am in this very strict religion
that everybody in this religion looked miserable.
Everybody in this religion,
like the whole time my daddy was a preacher
and I'd be looking up at them
and they'd be singing about Jesus
and they all look like they're about to cut their wrist.
And I remember at about seven years old,
looking up there and thinking,
if I've got to go to heaven with y'all
and spend eternity with y'all, I'd rather go to hell.
You know what I'm saying?
This is gonna be the most boring party in heaven ever.
And so I did this, I was on this perpetual cycle.
I was in religion, I stayed in it,
but I kept having my mind because I'm that rebel.
I'm kind of a rebel for Jesus.
And I found myself at 36.
36 was the golden number for me
because I had to move back in with my mom and dad
at 36 after a 17 year marriage ended.
And I had never heard from God for myself.
I had all my life put myself in this box
and I was trying to be an Ann Taylor
when God created me to be a Betsy Johnson.
I was like, this is boring.
So coming out of this 17 year marriage,
I really started finding myself and I found God for me.
I found out, I didn't want the God
that my mom and dad taught me about.
I wanted the God that I knew created the heaven
and the earth and didn't write me off.
He didn't take me off the clearance rack
and put me on the clearance rack
because I made some mistakes.
He knew before I was ever even thought in my mother's womb.
Evan, he knew that I was gonna be stubborn.
He knew that I was gonna walk through this divorce
and be the only one in my family that can't keep a man.
You know what I'm saying?
And so I think in that season, I started praying specifics.
Like I started learning how to pray for myself
and I would pray specifics and I would say things to God
like, God, I wanna be free from people.
Like I am letting these people
that go to the bathroom just like me,
they wake up with bedhead just like me,
they wake up with po-chop nasty morning breath like me,
they make felt, they've fallen like me
and yet here I am stuck because of what they think about me
and I wanna be free.
And so I went on a journey to get free
and whenever I did, man, when I tell you,
I remember at 40 years old, Evan,
I was still at Bloomingdale's working, doing cosmetics
and the reason I got these glasses on
is because my eyebrows are not on fleek.
Here I am in Bloomingdale's,
happened to put makeup on people
because I had to have a J-O-B
and because I walked through that divorce
and man, what the enemy meant for evil,
I had to go get that job
and I had to go work with people and hated people
and I had to learn how to do makeup on them
and in that process, Evan,
I started falling in love with people, their stories.
I'm sitting there making $9 an hour doing makeup on people
and pretending like I knew what I was doing and I didn't
and for 45 minutes, I would just encourage them
because look, you ain't gonna have a whole head
full of makeup when I get done with you
but I'm gonna need you to feel like you could own
this Bloomingdale's when you walk out
and so in that process of my healing,
I found out that my healing came from me loving
some, loving the hell out of somebody else
and so I went from hating people to loving people
is my favorite hobby on the planet
and I think that God has a sense of humor.
He said, I'm gonna let people sleep on you
because they already thought you'd have messed up
in the church world, can't nobody use you,
you are just written off, you have done the cardinal sin
and they're gonna be sleeping on you
and while they're sleeping on you,
I'm gonna be building you up for your next.
I'm gonna be building you up
for where I'm about to take you
and you thought, Kimberly, the curtain had closed
but the curtain had to close
so I could set up for the next scene
and so I watched over those five years,
God did something and 40 years old, I remember,
I did a conference.
I don't know whatever made me do a conference.
I didn't know how to preach and I was a special ed,
I didn't go to Bible school and I did a conference
and I named it Conquering Hell in High Heels
and I did that because women are the worst
at walking through something
and losing themselves and getting bitter Betty,
really getting, letting our emotions,
we can birth a whole baby out of a place
nothing should come out of
but yet we can't go through a breakup
or go through failure or go through social media,
scrolling on Instagram and wanting to be everybody else.
I just didn't get that
so I started Conquering Hell in High Heels
and we can go through hell and come out on fire.
We don't have to be bitter, we don't have to be angry,
we don't have to stay stuck on stupid,
we don't have to stalk them on Facebook,
we can get up, pick ourselves up
and realize the harder I fall, the higher I bounce
and so that's where I found, hey, I found my voice
and I started preaching in a tutu.
I just, you know what, I just got me some tutus
and I got me some combat boots, I took my heels off,
I took my Ann Taylor crap off and I put on a tutu
and I said, I'm gonna do this until I get free from people
and I did it for me and it took off.
Everybody was like, who is this crazy woman
and usually I got this big mohawk,
I got the pandemic hair right now
but I'm like walking up in there with this tutu on
and all of a sudden, all of these people
from all over the world were coming in with tutus on
and it was almost like a chance for us
to just get rid of what people thought about us
and I did it for two years
and when God started opening up major platforms for me,
I mean, man, in the last, so I thought at 36 years old,
my life was over, Evan, at 41 years old
is when I got to go full-time ministry
because I had a video go viral, go figure
and 42, I wrote my very first book with my special Ed self
and then at 46, I started my podcast that's blowing up
and at 47, which I am today,
I realized my life is just beginning
and so that's why I'm a hope dealer, man,
if God can do it for me, can do it for you,
all you gotta do is believe in yourself
and just put yourself out there.
I love it, she's preaching,
she's preaching right here on Instagram, I love it.
While you were talking, people were talking in the chat too
about self-censorship and just what I love about that story
is you just decided that I'm gonna go off
and launch my own event and I'm gonna show up in a tutu
and my Mohawk and my army boots and just do it.
So many people have that kind of version of themselves
in their head but then immediately it's,
well, I can't do a tutu and my own event
and so how do you get the courage to trust that idea
so that you don't censor yourself and jump into it?
Well, I just figure what do I have to lose?
I'm still living at my mom's, I'm working at Bloomingdale's
and I think I just got so crazy in love with the fact
that I was getting healed,
like I had been depressed my whole life
and I just started every day I would do it scared,
I would do something else scared,
like the worst thing that can happen, Evan,
is I write this book and nobody buys it.
You know what I'm saying?
But I still could say I wrote a book.
You know, the worst thing that can happen
is I start this conference and I even, listen,
I didn't even preach, I had other people preach
because I was still like, I can't preach, I'm still ratchet.
I'm from the south side of heaven, me and Tupac
and I just did it, you know?
I just started looking at it like the worst thing
that can happen is people laugh at me.
The worst thing that can happen is they don't like me.
And so what?
They don't like themselves.
And so I think that in life, you have to do it scared, Evan.
You have to do it.
You have to turn off the comments.
You have to open up your phone and do a Facebook live
and you can't wait for five or 10 people to come in.
You just have to do it and you have to do it scared
and you have to do it every day.
You have to be consistent.
You have to write in that book one hour a day.
You got to start on your business plan right now.
You can't wait.
You can't wait because see, one ounce of obedience
does more for you than all the prayer in the world.
We're wanting God to do all these great things for us, Evan,
but we won't even take a step.
We won't even move.
We're stuck.
We're like stuck like a turtle stuck in peanut butter.
You know what I'm saying?
We're over here just scared of people and do it scared.
Let them laugh at you.
If there's one single person that is about to commit suicide
and they hear your story and they're like, man, that girl,
she must have had crack for breakfast.
I don't know what she had, but I want whatever she's got.
And they open their ears to something
that's gonna change their life forever.
That one person is better than 20 million people.
It's better than that degree that you ain't never gonna use.
Just being able to be obedient and walking in your purpose
and your purpose is always connected
to helping somebody else.
It is.
And your story, your story is a game changer for somebody.
Evan, you're gonna touch somebody that I can never touch
all because you decided to get on here on a Thursday
at 12 o'clock and just open your mouth and talk to somebody.
You're gonna encourage one person
that if you wouldn't have been obedient to do this.
So that's what I would say.
I would tell people, do it scared.
Do it scared.
Go out on the limb.
The one thing that you are the most scared of doing, do it.
Do it and you watch what's gonna happen.
The thing that you're most scared of
is what you need to do.
Cause it's gonna be game changing.
Because the enemy, listen, thieves don't rob empty vaults.
Like the enemy is not trying to shut you up
because you're weak.
He knows there's something inside of you.
That's why you've had such a hard childhood.
That's why you had such a dysfunctional life.
That's why none of those relationships worked out.
Trying to beat you down.
He can't take you out.
So he's trying to wear you out.
So get up and do it.
Do it scared.
Even if nobody in your family supports you.
God will send complete strangers.
I promise you to support what you do.
You gotta do it though.
You gotta move.
Even if you're dragging your big old thick thigh, move.
Just move.
I love it.
I think we need some Pastor Kim ringtones
and morning alarms.
I feel like those would do super well.
Do it scared.
Sounds like the next book.
I just put a book out Evan last week called Shut Hell Up.
I wanted to say shut the hell up
but they wouldn't let me put the D in there.
But you know, that's what stops us Evan.
It's ourselves right here.
I'm not qualified.
I'm a nobody.
There ain't nobody in my family that's ever written a book.
There ain't nobody in my family ever done this.
And you are the one that's the game changer.
You are the nation shifter.
Like right there in your house Evan,
you have a whole Oprah studio right here.
We don't even know each other.
And look, because of your obedience
and because of my obedience, we're changing somebody.
Somebody is gonna get up today and do their purpose
because of our obedience.
How cool is that?
What?
That's better than winning the lottery
that somebody is walking in their purpose
because of our obedience.
So they need to move.
Somebody is waiting on y'all.
Somebody is waiting on you.
Shut the hell up.
Get going.
Show yourself shut the hell up.
You were talking about prayer a couple of times
and you said early on you prayed for specifics
and then people often pray and say,
they want God to come and fix all their problems.
So how do you pray for strategy?
Like how do you pray for, hey, give me the tools
to then go off and accomplish these goals of mine
instead of solve my problems for me?
What does that look like for you?
And I would pray every day because Evan,
I was a type that, man, just as rebel as I am for Jesus,
I was in the world.
Like I honestly would be nay-naying on a bar
thinking I was coyote ugly.
So I never do anything like halfway.
And so I didn't know what to do.
I didn't know how to start a book.
I didn't know, nobody in my family had ever,
my dad and mom gave me their church three years ago
to pastor and I'm just like,
there is 20 white people in this church.
Like I don't even wanna pastor this church.
I need to break these barriers.
And so I have learned in my life to pray specifics
to the point of God, I don't wanna stand in my own way.
And I know what you created me for
is way bigger than what I can think
because if Ephesians 3.20 says
that he's gonna do exceedingly, this is the word of God.
Like this ain't no chemism.
It says he's gonna do exceedingly abundantly
more than we could ever ask or think.
That means nobody in your family can even fathom
what Evan has potential to do, right?
And so God, I don't wanna stand in my own way.
I don't wanna have friends in my life
that I'm the smartest one in my group.
Like I want you to open doors
that I could never even get into.
I want my name to be in rooms
that my feet had never even stepped in.
Like I don't wanna be looking for a seat at the table.
I wanna build my own table,
but I have no idea how to do it.
So God, let's go.
Give me dreams.
Give me, let me open a picture.
Let me be standing in a grocery store line and see,
and that's how right my status is.
That's how everything in my life is done.
I just, it's like stuff just comes out of nowhere.
I stay uncluttered.
I don't allow people in my life
that are draining me and screaming.
They sucking the life out of me
when I'm giving them the straw.
I make sure that every day I am intentional.
I am intentional.
I am moving.
Just like as soon Evan as this pandemic hit,
I immediately started going in
because I traveled 51 weeks out of the year.
I lost a ton of money since this pandemic started.
And I thought, oh no, oh hell no, not today.
I started refocusing and I started saying,
God, help me refocus in this thing.
Help me know what to do to handle this.
Let me maneuver.
And that's what he does.
He gives you the desires of your heart.
He needs you to stop waiting for him to do it.
And you say, I'm ready to move my feet.
Just help me have direction.
And so I think writing book, reading books,
this is all important.
Getting around people that are where you want to go.
Get around people that are, don't already,
man, they ain't, they ain't,
they make me feel a certain way.
They, I'm not good enough for their circle.
I'll be wiping your shoes.
I'll be carrying your bags,
whatever I got to do to be in the presence of greatness.
Your job is to get, read books, listen to podcasts,
turn off Beyonce school and stuff,
but turn on some podcasts
where people are encouraging you, right?
Turn on some things in your life that are making you grow.
People that you look at and it's obvious
their fruit is producing.
Their fruit is producing.
And see that and get yourself in alignment with them
and say, I'll just catch your trickle.
I'll just catch your crumbs.
I'll do whatever.
It's there.
We're in social media world.
It's just up to you to go find it and grow.
It's up to you.
We're right here.
You should come out of this pandemic.
I changed person.
When people watching, they're feeling the energy,
I'm feeling energy, the hearts are flying, it's great.
When somebody wakes up then tomorrow,
how do you stay devoted?
How do you stay committed?
How do you keep that?
Yes, you can follow Real Talk Kim,
watch your content, watch the YouTube channel,
but what do you recommend that people do
to take the energy that they're feeling today
and not have it just reset back to zero tomorrow?
Shoo, it's intentional, man.
Because there are days I'll wake up.
People think that I'm always on crack or something
and I'm not like this.
Jesus is my Red Bull,
but I do wake up and I'm still overwhelmed.
We walk through things in life.
We walk through things in life that may wear us out.
We walk through divorce.
We walk through money issues.
We walk through being furloughed.
The only thing that you can do is make a choice
that I'm gonna be better than I was yesterday.
I'm not staying here.
I have a tendency to be depressed.
So I've gotta wake up, turn the blinds open.
If that is you, you go into depression,
put good stuff in your body.
You're gonna have to reprogram.
It's not always about becoming something.
Sometimes it's about unbecoming your habits
and begin to get in a place where you want it bad enough.
If you don't want it bad enough, you're not gonna get it.
Until you are sick and tired of being sick and tired,
you are not gonna change it.
You have to have a mind change.
You have to be intentional
and you gotta keep repeating these cycles
until it transforms you, right?
You gotta keep doing the good habits
until it outweighs the bad habits.
If you don't like something, change it.
If you're not obsessed with your life, change it.
You only get one chance and it's your decision.
Happiness is a choice and it's your choice.
Yep, not every day is gonna be great,
but every day is what you make it, period.
You can walk through hell
and still be dancing in the puddles.
You can, because it's a choice.
Instead of thinking of what you've lost,
think about what you've got.
I've got another chance.
I'm only 47 years old.
Yeah, this sucks.
Yes, it hurts.
Yes, I wasn't prepared for this,
but I still ate in the ground getting eaten by worms.
So that means I can dance my way out of this thing.
It may not be okay today.
It may not be okay tomorrow,
but today is my job is to renew my mind
and get myself in a position
where every time I wanna think something negative,
I switch my mind to something positive
because there's always something positive in your life
that you can think about and be thankful for.
She's the hope dealer.
It's right there, it's happening.
It's crazy how quickly time flies
when you're having fun.
Pastor Kim, if people wanna find you more
on Instagram, YouTube, your book,
like where do you want them to go?
What's the next step?
So I'm all over social media as Real Talk Kim and my books.
You can all get them anywhere books are sold
or you can get them on my website at realtalkkim.com.
Appreciate you.
Thank you for the energy, the love.
Evan, I like you, man.
Thank you.
I like you too.
Thank you so much.
Bye everybody.
If you wanna see the one-on-one I did with Bishop TD Jakes,
check out the video right there next to me.
I think you'll enjoy it.
Continue to believe and I'll see you there.